نعم،
بالقرب من الهجوم المضاد الوشيك لأوكرانيا
في الجنوب الشرقي
حيث تمارس روسيا الوحشية منذ فترة طويلة،
أصبح الألم أمرًا شائعًا والضرر غالبًا في
كل مكان عشوائيًا،
الهدوء نعمة نادرًا ما تدوم، لقد تم
تحذيرنا من ضربة صاروخية
قادمة ومغادرتنا
نستطيع  أشعر بالضغط
خلف سياراتنا المدرعة
الآن، هل يمكنك سماعي، جون منتجنا
في سيارتنا الثانية خلف
الدخان مباشرة، إيجور ماجليش ولا
يجيب مات، هل يمكنك سماعي، لقد
سقط الصاروخ بين
سياراتنا الآن، هل يمكنك سماعي؟
نات، هل يمكنك سماعي خلال 10 ثوانٍ،
ليس لدينا أي فكرة عما إذا كانوا بمفردهم حسنًا، لقد
قالت للتو شيئًا نات، هل يمكنك سماعي،
نعم، شكرًا لك،
نحن بخير، فقط اترك السيارة في الطريق الذي
غادرنا به،
نغادر معًا
للعديد من هذا الاختيار  المغادرة هو
شيء وهمي يحدث فوق
الأرض، حيث يوجد الماء والكهرباء الوحيدان في المدينة
هنا. لقد كانت الحياة تحت الأرض هنا
صعبة لبعض الوقت ولكنها
ستصبح أكثر صعوبة عندما
يبدأ الهجوم المضاد في الدفع
بالتأكيد في هذا الاتجاه
إذا كان هناك مساحة.  للضحك، إنه من
هذه
الكوميديا ​​التهريجية الصارخة التي تعود إلى الحقبة السوفيتية
حول رجل أبله مخمور يثني لفترة وجيزة
مجموعة التجهم السميكة هنا
[موسيقى]
أوروبية
يبدو أن الملائكة الحارسة هنا تطير في
بلدة مات فيها 50 شخصًا في الحرب وأصيب 200 آخرون
بسلامة  هي مجرد كلمة هنا
ورابل هي مكان
نيك بيتون والش CNN arahive أوكرانيا